en este vídeo y los siguientes quiero
hablar de dos términos muy importantes
en un contexto macroeconómico uno es la
oferta agregada y el otro es la demanda
agregada de hecho vamos a empezar con la
demanda agregada déjame escribirle por
aquí demanda demanda agregada
agregada y de una vez como ya mencioné
la oferta agregada la voy a escribir
también por acá oferta oferta agregada
agregar
si te acuerdas de los vídeos de
microeconomía también teníamos conceptos
similares allá también teníamos una
oferta y una cierta demanda así que en
estos vídeos quiero hacer mucho énfasis
en la distinción de estos dos modelos de
la demanda agregada y la oferta agregada
contra la demanda y la oferta regulares
o sea la demanda y la oferta en un
contexto de microeconomía para empezar a
hacer bien bien está esta distinción
déjame pasar aquí a la derecha para
acordarnos de la oferta y de la demanda
regulares de la oferta
y de la demanda de manda y vamos a ver
un pequeño repaso de cómo estaba la
curva de oferta y demanda en esta
situación para esto teníamos que
enfocarnos en una cierta industria o sea
no podía hacer algo muy muy arbitrario y
lo que hacíamos era trazar una gráfica
entonces teníamos por ahí los ejes de
este lado teníamos precio de este lado
teníamos cantidad cantidad de unidades
vendidas de chocolate o de no sé qué
paquete de cajas lo que sea entonces
aquí teníamos una curva de demanda que
se veía de esta forma déjame déjame
trazar la algo así tenía pendiente hacia
abajo
algo más o menos de este estilo y la
argumentación era básicamente la
siguiente habían dos formas de ver las
cosas una era que un precio alto hacía
que la gente demandará poco chocolate
porque si tienes un precio muy alto
entonces prefieres comprar chicles o
prefieres comprar paletas de modo
similar un precio bajo hacia que se
demandará una gran cantidad de
chocolates porque si estás enfrentado a
comprar un chicle de 5 pesos o un
chocolate de 2 pues prefieres comprar el
chocolate v2 otra forma de ver esto era
como una curva de beneficio marginal es
decir pues había una gran diferencia de
pasar de tener 0 chocolates a tener un
chocolate verdad entonces ahí sí había
algún cierto beneficio un beneficio un
cambio de beneficio grande y entonces si
hay un chocolate nada más puede darse el
lujo de tener un precio alto pero si hay
una gran cantidad de chocolates que
están ofrecidos en el mercado entonces
hay poco beneficio en pasar de tener
pues mil chocolates a tener mil un
chocolate y por tanto entonces pues no
este pues la gente no va a pagar tanto
por ese beneficio adicional y así
el precio tiene que ser bajo entonces
esto de acá era la oferta y la demanda
en un contexto microeconómico digamos en
la industria del chocolate y de modo
similar aquí vamos a tener una gráfica
de más o menos precio contra cantidad
que también va a tener una pendiente
negativa pero por razones distintas
entonces ahora vámonos para acá a la
izquierda y empezamos a pensar en toda
la economía sale en toda toda la
economía entonces cómo se vería ahora
una gráfica tendríamos de nuevo un eje
vertical que va a tener que ver con
precio tenemos un eje horizontal que va
a tener que ver con cantidad aquí abajo
la cantidad ya no va a ser la cantidad
dentro de una industria esta cantidad ya
tiene que ser así toda la cantidad de la
producción de la economía y eso ya
platicamos un poquito que lo podemos
pensar como el producto interno bruto y
le voy a poner real si para tomar en
cuenta este cosas de la inflación
entonces este es el producto interno
bruto real y de este lado que vamos a
tener pues algo similar al precio aquí
también va a ser que voy a poner la p de
precio pero
y precio no es el precio nada más dentro
de una de una zona de la industria sino
este es el precio de así algo como en
términos de toda la economía podría ser
el precio digamos de la canasta básica o
podría ser la suma promediada de varios
precios importantes o cosas por el
estilo entonces este precio es un precio
más como una variable macroeconómica que
microeconómica ok entonces déjame
dibujar la curva algo así
más o menos algo de este estilo entonces
algo así sería otra vez la curva de
demanda agregada en este contexto
macroeconómico de nuevo tiene una
pendiente negativa y esta curva
los economistas bueno creen que se ve
así bueno tienen teorías para justificar
que se ve así y por tanto pues están más
o menos alegres porque esto les permite
bueno a partir de ciertas suposiciones
les permite con esta herramienta pues
poder explicar algunos de los ciclos
económicos que tenemos o sea esto de que
teníamos contracciones y expansiones de
la economía y cosas por el estilo y les
permite explicarlo de una forma un poco
más matemáticas y sin fijarse tanto en
las emociones de la gente y cosas por el
estilo si viste el vídeo del ciclo
económico entonces sabrás que yo tengo
una idea un poco distinta pero bueno
vamos a seguir con esta cosa de acá y
entonces esta curva lo que dice lo
siguiente si tienes precios muy cerca si
quieres precios muy bajos entonces va a
haber una gran producción pero si tienes
precios muy altos entonces casi no va
haber producción a lo mejor estoy aquí
está un poco exagera
porque aquí en cero le había puesto un
pib de nada tenía un precio el cual el
pib podría ser cero pero a lo mejor no
queremos algo tan extremo déjame
pintarlo más como algo de este estilo va
entonces dijo no no es como que el
producto interno bruto desaparezca
porque el precio fue muy alto a lo mejor
esto debería de ir tangencialmente hacia
así esta recta de acá pero observa de
nuevo es una curva con pendiente
negativa otra vez es muy similar a lo
que sucede en esta cosa de acá y aquí
podría ser un poco anti intuitivo verdad
porque a lo mejor precios bajos uno
pensaría que es un indicador de que hay
poco dinero fluyendo porque pues la
gente paga poco entonces hay poco dinero
fluyendo entonces el bid no debería de
ser tan alto pero no hay que acordarnos
de una cosa esto ya que es una
suposición así 7x paribus te acuerdas de
esa cosa en latín eso quiere decir
considerando todo lo demás igual
entonces movimientos en el precio
afectan movimientos en el producto
interno bruto así ok entonces bueno por
eso no va a ser tan ante intuitivo
ahorita vamos a las razones pero
que como podemos justificar esto de acá
de este lado era como una cosa más o
menos tipo preferencia verdad o sea si
ya había muchos chocolates entonces este
pues no sé de la gente se iba a tal vez
altar de los chocolates y van a pagar
menos si hay pocos chocolates entonces
pueden ser como algo muy valioso algo
muy muy cotizado porque es escaso pero
de este lado este pues también tenemos
una pendiente negativa pero por otras
razones déjame contarte esas razones las
voy a escribir por acá hay hay tres
principales razones de bueno tres
teorías verdades razones es un poco más
fuerte más bien teorías que tienen los
economistas para explicar estoy acá para
la primera es el efecto riqueza el
efecto riqueza riqueza insisto si se
puede ver un poco anti intuitivo verdad
porque si tenemos si tenemos poco así
una cantidad de precios muy baja
entonces puede parecer que las empresas
ganan poco entonces pagan menos salarios
y pagan menos salario se demanda menos
verdad las personas tienen menos con que
comprar
no es así otra vez se te dispara bus
estamos pensando que la gente sigue
siendo optimista sigue teniendo la misma
productividad lo único que cambia en
esta economía es el precio entonces qué
sucedería
imagínate que un día te despiertas y
todo está a mitad de precio tú tienes
exactamente los mismos ahorros en tu
banco y siguen ganando exactamente lo
mismo pero todo está a mitad de precio
entonces qué sucede pues te sientes más
rico entonces te dan ganas de comprar
más cosas vas al súper este compras
aceitunas compras salmón y compras cosas
muy ricas a lo mejor te compras un coche
entonces al comprar ya comprar y al
comprar si necesitas bueno estás
demandando más cosas y por tanto estás o
sea a menor precio se está demandando
más de modo similar si despiertas un día
y todo cuesta el doble
entonces éste pues vas a decir chin ya
no soy tan rico soy medio pobre ya no
puedo gastar tanto y entonces vas a
demandar menos entonces esa es una de
las tres teorías hay una segunda que se
llama el efecto del ahorro y el interés
le voy a poner aquí efecto
en efecto del ahorro ahorro
e interés
que eres
eres y consiste en lo siguiente a ver
vamos vamos a recordar un poquito qué
sucede cuando la gente podía pues
ahorrar un poquito más de dinero va mira
supongamos que que bajan los precios
entonces ahorita ya las cosas cuestan
menos pero tú estás ganando lo mismo
entonces por aquí está tu barrita de el
dinero que tienes y de ese dinero tú vas
a querer gastar cierta parte y vas a
querer ahorrar otra parte voy a dibujar
tres barritas porque ahorita las voy a
ocupar entonces ahí tenemos tres
barritas pero si tienes los si estás
ganando una cierta cantidad de dinero
entonces pues usualmente lo que haces es
gastar un poco déjame ponerle ponerle un
poco más para acá
gastas un poco y lo demás lo ahorras
esto de acá lo ahorras ahorras pero si
de repente los precios bajan y nada más
estas requiriendo la misma cantidad de
cosas entonces ahora va a disminuir lo
que gastas estoy aquí es el gasto
y qué va a suceder con tu con tu ahorro
puesto ahorros va a aumentar y qué le
pasa al ahorro o sea tu ahorro que
ahorras te vaya pues entonces no lo vas
a no lo vas a guardar en tu colchón ese
dinero entra al sistema bancario lo
metes a un banco entonces ahora los
bancos pueden prestar más dinero y qué
sucede si se presta más dinero si de
repente todos los bancos pueden darse el
lujo de tener mucho dinero para prestar
entonces aumenta la oferta de dinero que
pasa se aumenta la oferta de dinero
entonces ahora el dinero es una cosa más
barata entonces rentar dinero ahora es
más barato entonces qué sucede pues baje
el precio de pedir prestado o sea en
otras palabras si baja el precio déjame
escribir esto por aquí
de forma abreviada si baja el precio
entonces eso lo que hace es que aumente
el ahorro aumenta el ahorro entonces
aumenta la oferta de dinero oferta de
dinero
lo cual hace que baje el precio del
dinero es decir bajan las tasas de
interés e interés
y si bajan las tasas de interés entonces
la gente puede pues ahora sí hacer
algunos proyectos que tenía en mente eso
lo que hace es aumentar la inversión la
inversión y cómo aumenta la inversión
déjame pasarme para acá como aumenta la
inversión entonces aumenta el producto
interno bruto el producto interno bruto
se expande
se expande expande de modo similar y
aumenta el precio entonces puedes
ahorrar menos ahora vas a tener que
gastar un poco más verdad déjame ponerle
aquí con el color que estaba usando
estoy aquí si aumenta el precio de las
cosas ahora puedes ahorrar menos entre
menos dinero al sistema financiero hay
menos oferta de dinero sube el interés y
por lo tanto el pib se contrae entonces
déjame abreviar esto de esta forma es
más bien si sube el precio si aumenta el
precio entonces baja la oferta de dinero
oferta de dinero dinero lo cual hace que
aumente el precio mayor interés
es menos inversión y por tanto el pib se
contrae
contra el vale pues el pip se contrae
todo esto es producto interno bruto real
bueno está de ahí es la segunda razón
por la cual puede pasar esto de acá que
esta curva tenga una pendiente negativa
y la tercera razón se llama el efecto de
cambio de divisas
efecto de cambio cambio de divisas de
divisas estoy acá está un poco más
interesante o sea que sucede otra vez si
baja el precio baja en las tasas de
interés va nos expresemos que baje el
precio bajan las tasas de interés y por
tanto qué pasa con personas que tengan
dinero en en un cierto país no sé
supongamos que en méxico de repente
bajan mucho las tasas de interés pues tú
si tienes muchos pesos no te conviene
que sean pesos verdad te conviene que
sean digamos dólares dólares de eeuu
entonces qué haces compras dólares de
eeuu y los préstamos allá a una mayor
tasa de interés así que tienes que ir a
tu a tu casa de cambio más cercana
comprar muchos dólares y ya después
préstamos pero si compras muchos dólares
eso qué quiere decir que si haces eso
entonces
y aumenta la oferta de pesos la oferta
de pesos
disminuye
aumenta la oferta de pesos aumenta la
demanda la demanda de dólares de dólares
ya lo mejor sería bueno que vieran los
otros vídeos de divisas porque en eso se
explica un poco más esto pero se aumenta
una cierta oferta de una moneda y
aumenta la demanda de otra entonces está
de esta esta moneda la primera se vuelve
más débil contra la otra entonces el
peso se debilita frente al dólar habrá
un peso compa compra menos dólares pero
no es bueno no es no es tan grave esto
finalmente porque qué sucede entonces ya
disminuye el peso ahora qué pasa con los
países de fuera entonces ahora las cosas
mexicanas se ven muy baratas por ejemplo
los coches mexicanos por decir algo los
coches que que fabricamos mexicanos no
sé si antes un coche pues no se es o sea
lo podías comprar digamos que déjame
agarrar otro color
este de acá entonces si antes un coche
lo podías comprar en términos de dólares
vamos a ponerle pues algo así como
30 mil dólares así un coche más o menos
caro en 30 mil dólares y de repente esta
cosa hace que se debilite el peso
entonces ahora a lo mejor un coche
mexicano lo vas a poder comprar digamos
en 25 mil dólares esto es muy drástico
pero ese es un ejemplo no entonces qué
sucede la gente de afuera ve que es muy
barato comprar cosas en méxico y por
tanto cómo empieza a comprar y comprar
cosas en méxico aumenta la exportación
en méxico aumenta la exportación y se
aumenta la exportación como eso es una
parte del producto interno bruto también
el pib aumenta va entonces aumenta la
exportación aumenta el pib entonces qué
pasó en total que un a un precio más
bajo
hizo que aumentara el producto interno
bruto también pasa exactamente lo mismo
al revés si se hace disminuye la oferta
de pesos entonces éste disminuye bueno
si disminuye la oferta de pesos y
disminuye la demanda de dólares entonces
ahora los coches mexicanos van a
aparecer más caros disminuye la
exportación y el producto interno bruto
también se contrae bueno nos vemos en el
próximo vídeo